all our life here be much harder losing
I think I want to where you're here you
found an art studio alright thanks
[Applause]
that's a lot of pressure
thanks Jared let me see if I can get the
mic working okay good okay great all
right all right tonight we are gonna
talk about after I get my password
entered here we're gonna talk about
machine learning with tensorflow and are
some of you may have heard of tensorflow
it's a open source library from google
it came out a little over two years ago
and from the time that tensorflow was
released i have been very excited about
what we could do with tensorflow from
our and hopefully i will communicate
that to you to communicate that well to
you tonight I've been working for the
past 18 months or so with a couple of
other folks from our studio on building
our interface to tensorflow and I'll
talk a lot about that work tonight
I'll start though by kind of giving you
an introduction to what exactly is
tensorflow kind of define it what are
the core components of it give you some
intuition about what it might be good
for the principal application of
tensorflow not not definitely not the
exclusive application the principal
application is deep learning so I'll
talk a little bit about deep learning
what is it again what is it what does it
how does it work
what is it useful for not useful for and
then I'll get into the work we've done
in our to let you use do deep learning
and other types of machine learning
using tensorflow
so first what is tensorflow
and you might and some of you might
answer oh that's a that's a deep
learning library that that Google is
created and that is true but it's
actually significantly more than that
tensorflow is actually a general-purpose
numerical computing library actually
it's applications go quite far beyond
deep learning or even even just machine
learning tensorflow is open source as I
said and one of the most interesting
characteristics of tensorflow I think
from our standpoint in the our community
is that it's Hardware independent so we
and our have been wrapping
miracle computing libraries for a long
time the original s language was
motivated by wrapping Fortran numerical
computing libraries and we've been
wrapping blast libraries which you can
see listed there we wrapped the the C++
eigen library we love wrapping numerical
computing libraries in our the cool
thing about tensorflow is that it's an
american computing library that runs on
all of the hardware and runs well and
all the hardware we have today and also
a potentially on future hardware so it
runs on the cpu and takes advantage of
all the cpu cores take some advantage of
parallel processing using sim D
instructions
it runs on GPUs it runs on a new piece
of hardware called a tensor processing
unit which is something that Google came
up with hardware specifically designed
to run tensorflow programs or tensor
flow models so that Hardware
independence is really critical
it also supports automatic
differentiation which is used
extensively in the in the deep learning
interfaces within tensor flow and the
whole system was built from the
beginning for scale it was built for
deployment it was built for distributed
parallel execution it was built to work
with very large datasets
so it's an it's a numerical computing
library that's really really powerful
interesting and built to scale so why
should we care well all the reasons I
just talked about a new numerical
computing library for us to build
beautiful our interfaces to a couple
other things I didn't mention the
optimization algorithms intensive flow
the whole system is built with the
presumption that all the data is not
going to be in RAM so the optimizers
don't require that all the data is in
RAM most optimizers that we might use or
many optimizers we use with machine
learning have the assumption that all
the data is in RAM that sumption is not
there with tensorflow and the other
thing that I'll get into a little bit
later is that when you deploy a
tensorflow model you don't bring along
any our code with that or Python code
it's just deployed against a C++ runtime
so you know traditionally an R will do
exploratory work we'll build models and
then when we deploy them it can be a
challenge to bring R along with along
with that the whole model of deployment
is that you don't use a C++ runtime for
deployment all right so some of the
basics of tensorflow what is a tensor
what's flowing you
how does it work what are some uses of
it tensors actually you're all already
familiar with tensors and you use them
all the time in are they're just a
raised specifically multi-dimensional
arrays so a vector which was pretty much
we all use all the time in our is a 1d
array a matrix is a 1d tensor
a matrix is a 2d tensor and then R
actually supports 3d and 4d and ND
arrays using the array function or a
data type 0 D tensor is a scalar which
are actually does not have a scalar data
type but you can think of a scale or
conceptually as a vector that's always
of length 1 so pretty much tensors are
what we already use in our to do most of
our computation so that's really nothing
new some examples of tensors and how
they play out in tensor flow one of
these I want you to note is that the
first dimension is always samples
there's always you know n number of
these things that were that were
considering so when we think about
vector data like a data frame we can
convert our data frame to a matrix
that's a 2d tensor
samples are the rows and the features
are the columns that's a 2d tensor so
that's very common in our 3d tensor a
time series would be an example of a 3d
tensor and we do represent time series
objects and are kind of in 2d but if you
think about it there's the the features
and then the steps like a data frame but
then your time series actually
considering a sequence of observations
how they relate to each other so that's
really a 3d data structure that the
models considering it's considering
multiple steps at one time images are an
example of 4d tensors you might think of
an image as a 3d data structure you'd
think height width and then color
channels red green and blue but it's in
tensor flow it's a 4d tensor because you
have multiple images so I'm gonna feed
4d tensors say 10 images each of which
has 3 dimensions and so the whole tensor
itself becomes four dimensions so all
the data you feed into these models is
one of these it's a 2d 3d 4d or in the
case of a video that would be like a 5 D
tensor because the video is just a
sequence of images so that's just
defining the term usually when you're
actually coding you're basically
dealing with matrices and some you know
essentially arrays that compose that
stack multiple matrices together so
what's the flow part of this what does
that represent
well tensor flow models or tensor flow
programs are not like ordinary scripts
in our or other programming languages
actually a tensor flow program is a data
flow graph the tensors the data flows
through the graph and then the graph has
operations in it the operations are sort
of like functions they're matrix
multiplications or additions of bias
terms or taking a gradient so the the
the the program is represented as this
data flow graph rather than just as a
script as you might be as you might be
accustomed to and I'll get into why
that's actually beneficial in a second
when you're actually working in R though
typically with high level interfaces to
tensorflow you're not actually building
the graph directly I'll explain this
code later this is some R code that
basically builds a Karass model and
neural network and you're just here
you're just declaring layers of the
neural network there's nothing about
graphs or nodes or operations that is a
picture of what the actual tensor flow
graph that's created as a result of this
model again you don't usually program
that directly although you can if you
want to there are interfaces for
interacting directly with the graph and
more innovative applications of tensor
flow might might want to take advantage
of that so what is the motivation for
this data flow graph why do we have a
graph well I can think of a couple other
analogs in R of intermediate
representations that make this a little
more intuitive so when you write a shiny
application you have a set of inputs and
outputs and reactives that is actually
effectively a graph of how the inputs
and the outputs every application relate
to each other and when shiny runs your
graph it can actually be smart about oh
this input changes so I only need to
execute this reactive in this output so
so shine is another example of a graph
that bite bite bite sighing knowing the
structure of your user interface can run
it more efficiently when you write deep
liar code that works against a like a
relational database the deep liar code
is going to create sequel the sequel is
an intimate representation of your query
and that is going to get fed to a sequel
optimal
that's gonna run the query really fast
so the motivation for the graph is
basically speed performance scalability
portability so so by getting your model
into this graph it actually can be run
in parallel it can be run in parallel
across multiple machines the operations
can be compiled in an intelligent way
like fusing together related output
operations and then we get this
portability attribute where when you
deploy your model it's just running with
c++ it's not running with r or python so
that's kind of the motivation so that's
really at the lowest level what's going
on with tensorflow
and what so what are people doing with
this I'm gonna get into some of these in
more specific detail later but we have a
gallery on our tensorflow for our
website that basically has a bunch of
blog posts that write up some different
applications people are doing a lot of
deep learning with tensorflow which
typically and will might involve some
computer vision
it might involves natural language
processing speech recognition it might
involve doing the analysis of really
noisy time-series data there are people
are doing conventional machine learning
things like support vector machines with
tensorflow so there's lots of things
people are doing with it but because
it's a general-purpose numerical
computing library there are other
applications of it that may not that you
may not have thought of and I actually
I'm actually quite excited for the our
community to kind of get their head
around this and figure out what what
might be possible I'll give you one
example of this that's already happened
in the art community there's a project
called Greta which is similar in aims to
bugs and Stan the idea is writing
statistical models and fitting them with
MCMC but the way Greta approaches the
problem is that you write our code
rather than writing in a special
language to define the model you just
write regular our code you can see a
comparison of some Greta code and some
bugs code and then that code actually
gets compiled into a tensor flow graph
and therefore that code can you know
train on huge datasets can run fast can
train fast on multiple CPUs and GPUs can
be deployed so this is actually written
using the are interfaced of tensorflow
and it's taking advantage that
underlying numerical computing and
automatic differentiation to do
something that really has nothing to do
with with deep learning so hopefully
we'll see many more
patience like this so now I want to get
into a little bit of what is deep
learning and what's it useful for should
we care about it now later kind of the
motivation for why why even why even
spend time on learning about doing deep
learning with our so at the at the very
very highest level what is deep learning
it's really this is an example of a
handwritten grayscale image of a
handwritten digit and we're trying to
build a model that will predict what
that digit is so really what deep
learning is is I have an input domain
like an image and I have an output
domain a prediction I have inputs and
outputs observations predictions and I'm
gonna build a set of I'm gonna change
the representation of that image to get
closer and closer and closer to my
output domain it really it's stacking
layers together that progressively
transform the representation of data
until it gets close to the output or the
prediction that you want that's what the
fundamental mechanic of deep learning so
what are layers the some of you may have
seen you know neurons and neurons
activating other neurons you don't I
don't talk about that at all here you
can think of a layer as just a data
transformation function that is
parameterized by coefficients or weights
so they're just big functions sometimes
a layer could have to have a hundred
coefficients and it's going to do some
kind of a transformation of the data and
we have to learn what the weights are to
do the correct transformation so it's a
geometric transformation parameterize by
set of weights that's really what a
layer is and when I talk about
representations what am I talking about
here so there's a really trivial example
of how changing a representation gets us
closer to the the prediction domain or
the output domain we're looking for I
have a bunch of points I want to
classify whether they're predict whether
a point is going to be a new point is
going to be white or black by changing
the coordinate system I've made the
prediction quite trivial because when I
change the coordinate system now if X is
greater than zero
the point is black and if it's
than zero the point is white so you
might think of this or know of this if
you do machine learning as feature
engineering where you're transforming
your inputs or features into ways that
are amenable to modeling and deep
learning model the feature engineering
is basically learned the we don't do a
lot of hand tuning of features before we
feed them into the model instead the
layers are the feature engineering so
there are transformations that probably
aren't this trivial but sort of
transformations like this again to get
us closer to the prediction domain so
going back to the example of the of the
handwritten scale digit as we go through
the layers of the model we're discarding
kind of the appearance of the digit and
we're kind of learning filters that let
us see okay there's there's shading
there's there's a there's an edge
there's a slanted edge and as we go
through the layers of the model I'll
kind of explain a little more how this
works later we go from just the
appearance of the digit to something
that's closer and closer to the actual
prediction which then on the final layer
we get so we're stripping out with
distilling data by stripping relevant
information and trying to get closer to
the essential thing trying to predict so
that is where the term deep comes from
in deep learning it's not deeper insight
or deeper models its layers it's many
layers you you could call it equally
well layered representation learning or
hierarchical representation learning
those might be like more slightly more
precise terms but it's called deep
learning because well these layers and
in the number of layers I showed for
there could be there could be ten there
could be 50 there could be a hundred
layers depending on on the application
so typical typically machine learning
models will tend to feature engineering
and then one or two layers deep learning
has many many layers that's why it's
called deep learning and what can we do
with this technique with this different
approach to to mapping inputs to outputs
or observations to predictions well deep
learning has accomplished quite a few
things in I would call in the perceptual
domain so computer vision image
classification speed
recognition handwriting transcription
some things in natural language
processing some of these things have
been composed together to do things like
autonomous driving so deep learning is
able to learn very very complex
functions functions that we haven't been
able to learn with previous machine
learning techniques how is it how is
this possible to give you some intuition
you think about a paper ball I think
about like trying to write a linear
equation for UNCHR um pulling a paper
ball you it would be really difficult to
do that but if you think about what a
human being
uncredible is a paper ball they're just
gonna do 30 or 40 little simple
transformations to pull apart the paper
ball until it's flat and that is you
know in a way really what a deep
learning model is doing it's gonna learn
the sequence of simple transformations
to ultimately do something very complex
to learn a very very complex function
and that's why I think it's worked
better on some of these very very
complex perceptual tasks so why should
we care about deep learning I think
there's two axes to consider here one is
deep learning plays in domains that we
don't do a lot of in are so things like
computer vision and computer speech
recognition there are some reinforcement
learning applications of kind of writing
models that know how to interact with
their environment to play games or do
other things we don't really do that
much in our we do we do definitely do
some computer vision and certain in
geospatial applications and some
biomedical applications so we do
computer vision but but we don't do a
ton of it so this this opens up kind of
being able to use deep learning from our
opens up some new problem domains to us
but I think what's more interesting is
to think about does do these tools give
us improve techniques for the domains
traditionally of interest to our users
is there data that we have that has very
complex sequence or spatial dependencies
that's hard to model too noisy to model
is there data that we have to do a ton
of feature engineering engineering on
that may be kind of brittle to get good
models out of so maybe this will provide
some techniques for our traditional
domains I think you know spoiler it
might it might not it's not proven that
these techniques are gonna are going to
revolutionize any of the things that we
traditionally do in statistical modeling
and
and a lot of machine learning it's
definitely proven to be very good way
better than than what's come before in
these perceptual tasks but it's a work
in progress but it's a work that a lot
of people are engaged in there are a lot
a lot of people kind of coming at can we
use these tools that have done so
remarkably on these perceptual tasks to
help us with other data analysis tests
so I'll get into more of that later on
on the talk so before I do that I want
to just just describe a little bit the
mechanics of how deep learning models
are trained and kind of go through that
handwritten digit example again in some
more detail and talk about kind of the
training loop the basic mechanic and
I'll hopefully in doing this convince
you that this is actually a really
straightforward mechanism that kind of
once it's been scaled up can do these
really really remarkable things so a
word first about kind of statistical
modeling versus machine learning I'm not
going to get really into this topic but
I think it's important to state upfront
that statistics is often focused on
explanation on understanding on kind of
figuring out the process by which data
is generated and machine learning and
deep learning in particular is really
heavily focused on prediction it's not
something that really yields
explanations or understanding and you
get more intuition about why that is
later so that's a difference there's a
number of Link's here to kind of read
more about that but it's different than
some of us who predominately do
statistical modeling and way of thinking
about data analysis problems so let's go
back to this handwritten digit
recognition later on on the talk but
basically an R we're going to define a
model that is composed of a set of
layers there will be certain types of
layers we're using there'll be certain
parameters of those layers we're trying
to define the right layers that we'll be
able to learn the task here of
predicting a digit and then those layers
will be trained to do these these
representational transformations that
I've talked to you about before so how
does that exactly work well when a deep
learning mouse starts we have layers and
we have weights the weights are the
coefficients that we're trying to learn
at the beginning the weights are
initialized they actually are complete
garbage so the predictions that you get
off the on the first batch of samples
are gibberish they don't do anything so
we're gonna start training our model by
having again randomly initialized
weights we're going to feed data into
the model and we're going to see how our
predictions are and they're not going to
be very good so what we're going to do
is we're going to measure the quality of
the predictions by using a loss function
the data that we feed them to the model
we actually know when we feed the four
in we know it's a four and we see what
the MA oh the model predicted a five
okay or I thought it was maybe a four
but probably a five so we compare the
predictions and we generate a loss score
and we use that loss to update the
weights to learn the coefficients of the
model and that's the job of an optimizer
which basically translates the loss core
into a set of updates to the weights so
this is the basic mechanic we're going
to feed through thousands and thousands
of batches of data we're gonna start
with weights that are random and we're
gonna eventually learn weights that
actually cause the model to do what we
hope it hope it's gonna do what we
wanted it to do and if you think about
this is a really simple mechanic and
actually the mathematics behind it are
really straightforward this tweet is
from Francois who's the creator of the
Charis library and he's saying these are
not neuro they're not even networks
they're just this chains of functions
trained with this really straightforward
gradient descent algorithm so it's a
really straightforward mechanic but it's
done all these incredible things
really we've created this mathematical
machine for unn crumpling these really
complicated paper balls so how does this
work that the the why is it that this
works so well and actually the the ideas
behind neural networks were invented
decades ago so we've actually known
about all these things for a long time
and they haven't started working well
until very recently and it turns out
that that the key to making them work
well is to have really large models
trained on lots and lots of data and the
reason we can have really large models
or there's some algorithmic advances
that enable that but there's also GPUs
and modern CPUs that can be
used to train really large models and we
have the Internet and the digitization
of many many elements of modern life
that have created lots and lots of data
so it's the kind of hardware algorithmic
advances and more data have actually
made these models work so when I say
large parametric lots of parameters give
you some intuition about that the
grayscale digit recognizer a simple
greyscale digit recognizer this is the
same one I showed you the code for
earlier has 1.2 million coefficients or
1.2 million parameters that's a really
simple it's just greyscale digits it's
not doing much at all
if I build a model that can recognize
everyday objects a model that can that
can look at color images of you know and
say is it a cat is it dog Ian's at a
table is it a chairs at a cloud that is
gonna have about 138 million parameters
and that model is trained on 14 million
images so when I say large that's what I
mean large not like a hundred like 138
million so that's that's one of the
things that's that's that sort of
enabled this breakthrough these really
really large models trained on lots and
lots of data so what's happened is that
there are frontiers now where especially
in computer vision we've hit new
frontiers where we're able to do things
that we could never do before and people
are really excited about that
we've started to see some frontiers
emerge in natural language processing
natural language translation and people
are working in other fields to see do
these techniques apply can we get two
other frontiers can we find other
breakthroughs so some people are working
in time series things are going on in
biomedical applications so that's kind
of a thing for us
it's these frontiers some of the
frontiers are already explored and we
can benefit from those and some of those
the frontiers are there for us to
explore so really important to that this
computer vision this really touched off
the kind of intense interest in these
techniques across computing and data
science so there's a competition called
the image net challenge that's run from
2010 to 2017 where there's 3.2 million
labeled images you know it's a
it's a car it's a it's a cat it's a dog
it's a chair etc and machine learning
researchers competed to see who could
build the best models for identifying
what's in the image and when they
started the contest in 2010 the accuracy
was in the low 70s I think it was 72
percent that was the best that machine
learning researchers could do in 2010 so
in 2012 one team entered the contest and
used deep learning and they beat the
entire field by ten point eight percent
and subsequent to that everybody started
trying to figure out how to how to do
computer vision with deep learning and
in 2017 we were at ninety seven point
three percent so in the span of seven
years we went from 72 percent to 97
percent and that is really what got
people so excited and the reason people
are looking turning up every rock they
can trying to figure out do these
techniques work well for what I'm doing
see yeah so people are looking hard at
natural language processing and this is
a one indicator could be indicator
that's just a fad or it could be
indicating a fundamental shift but the
graph on the right shows the percentage
of deep learning papers at computational
linguistics conferences and it's over
that same time period it's gone from the
mid 30s up to 70 so a huge amount of
activity there this paper these slides
are will be available I'll share a link
to these slides after the talk you can
you can find a reference to this paper
does a roundup of some of those of some
of that work and has found that there
definitely progress is being made that
field is not being revolutionized but
progress is being made in a number of
areas in natural language processing one
area in particular that huge progress is
made is in language translation Google
published this I think in 2000 maybe in
late 2016 or sometime 2017 their neuro
machine translation system which beat
their previous phrase based translation
system significantly and is getting
closer to human levels of language
translation so that's that's another
huge win that's language translation
there are there are many other things
people do in natural language processing
and people are hard at work trying to
figure out where else can we do
interesting things with deep learning
and natural
it's processing some of the same things
are going on a time series honestly
almost almost all time series analysis
the conventional time series statistical
modeling tools that we have will be deep
learning in certain areas of really
noisy datasets with like overlapping
seasonality people feel like maybe deep
learning models could be better this is
a paper that tries to use convolution
which is the technique typically used
for doing computer vision on some time
series and compares it to some
conventional methodologies another paper
that uses a different approach and an
autoencoder to try to predict they're
doing predicting financial I think stock
prices so there's there's research going
on an experimentation going on in time
series and this field is not is not
turning upside down because of deep
learning I think it's I think in general
if people are getting wins here they're
probably spending several weeks on their
model and then getting the win they're
not just okay let me try a deep learning
bird notice oh look it's better that
doesn't happen the biomedical field
there's a lot of stuff people are
looking at everything from things like
just patient classification
treatment recommendations even looking
into into various biological phenomena
this is another paper that rounds up
what's going on there again
it's not changing the whole field but
there have been lots of promising
advances so again worth paying attention
to if you work in this or related field
this is a very interesting study it kind
of indicates the visit axis is a paper
that just came out last month it sort of
indicates the the the very different
approach that deep learning models take
from conventional statistical modeling
techniques so this is a study that
Google and Stanford and New York Chicago
School of Medicine and University of
California San Francisco did together
and they looked at electronic health
records which are very messy there's all
kinds of missing data that data is not
well normalized you know it's collected
in one way at one Hospital and or
geography and another way and another
one so really really messy data
typically when you want to build
statistical models against electronic
health records you have to curate and
normalize the data extensively so you're
going to pick out okay we're going to
pick out a subset of features we're
sure they're properly normalized a we're
going to impute certain data so this
very very labor-intensive process of
kind of picking out the data we're gonna
analyze so we can so we can actually use
this to pull model against it but in
doing that we're actually discarding a
huge amount of data all that messy data
we discarded is gone it's not part of
our analysis data like the notes that a
physician makes gone so what they did
was they said let's take all that data
and let's try to have the deep learning
model consider the entire medical record
we're not going to clean anything we're
not normalizing we're gonna look at the
physicians notes and the network is
going to figure is it's going to sort of
do its own normalization do its own
culling of the data and see if it can
learn a better model and in this study
they got predictions that were better
than what they would they got trying
traditional predictive models that could
be a strawman what they what they tried
but here they found better predictions
the if you notice the people who are on
this paper one of them is he's the
architect of tensor flow so it's not
just like anybody can get these kind of
results I think I think Google tried
pretty hard to get these results but it
may be that as this is an example of a
technique that may we may gain broader
understanding how to apply and it could
change the way we do certain types of
prediction so as you'd imagine there are
there are many problems with deep
learning models I referred to one which
is that there they are blackbox models
you cannot model with 138 million
coefficients you can't look at the
coefficient and say look we understand
this phenomena much better so they're
they're total blackbox models they are
they can be very brittle so if you look
give you google for adversarial examples
there's one you'll probably find which
is like a picture of a panda and another
panda and they look identical but one of
them has been doctored to trick the the
image classifier into thinking it's not
a panda by just changing little little
things that a human brain would never do
that human brain has a far more
sophisticated set of mechanisms at work
and I could see it's a panda it's not
even a question but these models can be
fragile so you can trick them easily and
there's ways that are being pursued to
tend to overcome adversarial examples
you can think of like
in autonomous driving you want to make
sure there's not like an adversarial
example of a sign that is misinterpreted
so that this is a serious problem for
the field but that's out there they
typically require a lot of training data
to perform there are ways to do what's
called transfer learning where you can
get the knowledge from one model and
move it into a smaller data set I'll
talk a little about that later but
mostly they require a lot of des and
they're very very computationally
expensive to train so there are a lot of
problems and a lot of reasons that they
that you know that they don't work well
for certain things one of the biggest
problems that was actually the hype that
has emerged around these techniques
driven by some of these big successes in
perceptual tasks and actually the the
current generation of tools makes deep
learning accessible to people who've
never done statistics or modeling so
they can build a model and they're
really excited about it and it's deep so
it must be good and it's actually like
way more expensive to train than a
statistical model and way worse and
accuracy so this is we're all going to
be trolled by this you know and the
years ahead and we can on the one hand
could say well the deep learning stuff
is snake-oil and don't pay attention to
it it probably doesn't work or we can
try to say well let's have a more
balanced dialogue about where this can
be used and how it can actually be made
better I think I think that's the thing
to do because in spite of the problems
it's really useful and you know you can
see at Google they came out with
tensorflow in you know the line here
says q3 of 2014 and it's just the use
inside Google has skyrocketed they've
found uses for it in many products in
many applications so I think we got to
try to find help deep learning find its
appropriate place in the domains we work
in rather than just say oh there's so
many things wrong with it it's not worth
spending any time or bandwidth on so I
want to talk a little bit now about the
work we've done in our to let you use
build deep learning models and use
tensor flow from ours so we have some
very high-level our interfaces you've
seen a little bit of that already we
have low-level interfaces to enable kind
of new applications like Greta and we
have some other tools to help with your
workflow so and hopefully we've also
invested quite a bit in sort
educational resources so you can learn
more about how the stuff works
so there's actually three sets of
high-level api's to tensorflow from our
there's the Charis api which is this
high level interface for neural networks
there's the estimator API which sort of
a classic linear regressor linear
classifier classic machine learning
those API almost look like our modeling
functions and then there's the core API
which is this low level access to the
graph which which was used like for
Greta and can be used for other kind of
innovative applications and research and
this this then sort of ends up there's
actually seven are packages that give
you interfaces to tensorflow there's one
for each of those interfaces there's a
package called TF datasets that that
deals with giving you access to very
large data sets from tensor flow models
and we have some supporting tools for
deployment experiment management and
doing cloud training so I'll talk a
little bit about all this in a minute so
the Charis api we're going to actually
talk quite a bit a bit about that today
that's the high level API again you're
just saying these are the layers I want
and then you fit your model from there
again I'll drill into this more later
that's really the the kind of the
preferred API there's this estimator API
that again it looks like our model the
trishal are modeling you say I want to
create a linear aggressor or a linear
classifier you can actually do neural
networks with this but they're specified
at a really high level you say well I
want you know six layers and I want them
to be this width it's not anything like
the granularity you get with Kerris so
they're really the way to do neural
networks is with carrots and the way to
do some of these more straightforward
models as estimators and then the core
API actually lets you're actually
computing directly on the tensor flow
graph way lower level you can see here
I'm actually defining my lost function
explicitly doing my training loop
explicitly so again I don't recommend
people use this interface unless they
want to in a again interact directly
with the graph or do things like like
Greta but we have this interface for
people who want to use it so let's talk
a little bit more about Karis kind of
step through an example and talk about
some of the different components of the
Charis API before I do that I want to
just describe a little motivation about
why Karis and actually Google is now
emphasizing Karis and
specially in the last six six or nine
months as the preferred interface to
tensorflow
if you look at what's this is on the
left kind of web search interest in deep
learning frameworks and you can see in
the last year or two the interest in
tensor flow and caris has just taken off
on the right is interestingly these are
this is actually from about a month ago
there's a website called archive which
has all the research that's done in deep
learning is generally published to
archive and and there you see a lot of
tensorflow but you see a huge amount of
Karass so it's really interesting that
Kerris is used it's sort of really
popular easy to use API for
practitioners but it's also used quite a
bit by researchers so so it's it's quite
it's quite flexible and quite adaptable
so that's why we put a lot of energy
into the our interface to Kharis so I'm
gonna walk you through a cara straining
script the different components of it
and this will be for this application of
recognizing handwritten handwritten
grayscale images of handwritten digits
the first step is always going to be
pre-processing and that's going to
basically be giving your data whether
it's sitting in a CSV file or it's
sitting in a directory full of images or
sound files or text documents and
somehow getting that into tensors you're
going to turn whatever your raw data is
into vectors matrices 3d arrays etc so
there's a pre-processing step then
there's a step where you define the
model by basically saying these are the
layers I'm going to use in my model and
you know it's not the the process of the
model definition it looks like oh I just
have to type in these five layers it
ends up being the case to get a good
model you're gonna play with these
layers like hundreds of times so it's
not a lot of code but it is a lot of
effort to get a model that works well
which layers stack how with what
parameters really determines the quality
of the model after you've defined the
model you compile the model by basically
saying what loss function do I want to
use what optimizer do I want to use and
what metrics do I want to collect to
judge how my model is performing before
I go and I want to make one comment
about this model compile statement you
notice that I'm not assigning the result
of that statement back to the model I'm
actually modifying the model object in
place and that is not typically how
things are done in our typically our
objects are by value you pass an object
in if changes are made to it a copy is
returned caressed models don't work that
way because they're actually these
complex a cyclic graphs of layers layers
can appear in more than one place in a
model and that those representations are
shared so they're their objects that are
modified in place so I say model
compiled and that actually changes the
model that's just you may not quite
understand how this code works unless
you know that piece about the objects
being modified in place all right so
we've defined our model we've compiled
our model and now we're going to train
our model by calling fit fit basically
takes the data the x and y and then it
has a few other parameters it says how
many samples at a time am I going to
give to the model in this case I'm gonna
give 128 samples at a time how many
times am I gonna traverse the input data
set again I have to I have to look at
the data thousand you know many many
many times over to get a good model so
here I'm going to say look and scan
through all of the data ten times and
then the other thing I'm going to
specify here is that hold out 20% of the
data for validation because if you have
a deep learning model that's big enough
it will just memorize your data so
that's one technique if you let it do it
it'll just memorize your data that is
not a model that generalizes well you
know memorization so what we do is we
hold out 20% of it and we constantly
test our model against the held out data
to make sure it's not just memorizing
that the input data so that's what that
is
so we fit them all you can see we
noticed we returned a history object
from the fit and we can see that we can
plot the history and see how did
accuracy and loss change over all the
epochs of the models training this is a
really good model because accuracy and
loss of converging validation is the
same as the validation accuracy is the
same as the training accuracy so we're
not we're generalizing well but a lot of
times this looks nothing like this
you'll see overfitting you'll see your
validation data getting worse
as your as your regular training
accuracy it's better so this is a
diagnostic tool that you use to figure
out how well how well training is going
on how well your model is working when
you're done with that you you can have
there's an evaluate step there's a yet
another
bit of data that's been held out data
that the models again has never seen
before and you haven't used for tuning
parameters that you can use to assess
the model and then you can generate
predictions just like you do there's a
predict method there's predict classes
generate predictions what you normally
do do an AR from a model so I'll give
you a quick demo of how that works looks
inside our studio is the same training
script and I'll start by loading the day
of the amnesty to set the grayscale
images that actually comes with Kerris
so I just load that up and then I take
my data and I reshape and scale it in
various ways until I basically got as
you can see I've got a few matrices that
I'm gonna feed into the model so that's
you can see over here I've got my
matrices intervene in the model and then
I define the model compile the model I
can I should print a summary as I showed
before in some other slides one of the
layers how many parameters this model
has two hundred thirty five thousand so
it's less complex model than the other
one I showed you and then I'll fit the
model and as I fit the model we're gonna
show you real time metrics because it's
just really important because a lot of
times models training doesn't go well
you start to see the validation accuracy
get worse the models plateaued so it's
really important to get real-time
feedback about how the model is doing as
its training and you can usually then
you'll interrupt the model and try
something else once you get the true the
history back you can plot the history
and that will give you that same plot
you can you can actually get a data
frame back and do your own plots
evaluation I showed you on the slide and
then generating some prediction so
that's a basic workflow this is a pretty
simple caris training script they can
get a lot more complicated than this but
this is the kind of demonstrates the
basic mechanics for training then this
model does actually perform at about
ninety eight percent accuracy on
handwritten digits which is pretty good
for such a simple and straightforward
model
right okay so getting a little more into
the Keirsey API we've talked about
layers there's the art of building these
models is basically figuring out which
layers to use and how to compose them
and so there's actually 65 different
layers I'm not even gonna bother
enumerator layers there's 65 different
layers that are built into carrots that
do different things and you can actually
also create your own layer so you can
write custom layers just to give you a
sense of categorically the types of
layers that are to give you a flavor of
some of the differences there are dense
layers and again this is the classic
like 1970s intro network of perceptrons
and all connected you know one layer of
neurons connected to another layer of
neurons to another layer of neurons
they're kind of the staple of neural
networks and and even more complex
models typically will have these models
these dense layers at the bottom a kind
of a staple workhorse basic neural
network layer
there are convolutional layers that are
typically used for computer vision
the idea behind convolutional layers is
that there's there's patterns of data
inside an image or some kind of other
data structure that are location or
translation invariance so like edges or
shadows or you know at a higher level
like eyes and if you see an edge or a
shadow or an eye in one part of the
image you should be able to recognize it
in other parts of the image so
convolutional layers basically learn
these filters and the filters are then
kind of slid over the whole image to
look for these things so once a filter
has learn to find an eye if it sees an
eye on the upper right-hand quadrant and
then sees an eye on the upper left-hand
cognate quadrant it can still recognize
it so again these are used a lot of
times for finding patterns in in
computer vision applications but you can
see people have used them for time
series and and that sort of thing two
recurrent layers are basically layers
that can maintain state so if I'm
looking at a set of input data the
current set of input data I'm I'm trying
to make a prediction based on that but
in the case of sequence data time series
data or text data it also matters what
I've seen before so recurrent layers or
layers that can accumulate
kind of a vector of state information
they can learn us a vector of state
information and that's used to condition
the the predictions to the next layer so
there's a recurrent layers again used in
time series used in a lot of natural
language processing applications
embedding layers for those of you who do
natural language processing you'll
recognize this the idea is that if you
look at text you could look at text as
just a classification so I have the word
dog and I have the word cat and they're
just two different words and there's
10,000 different words and they're just
two of them or you could learn a
representation of the word that reflects
that the fact that there's a there are
semantic relationships like cat and dog
they're both house pets they're both
mammals so embedding layers try to learn
richer representations of kind of
categorical data in this case like text
data and so there are many layers that
can actually learn those vectorization
zazz you train or you can actually take
pre train word embeddings that have
already been developed using other
techniques like word Tyvek and load
those into embedding layers so that just
gives you an idea of like three of the
different types of layers there are and
and really the trick of building these
models is to recognize what kind of
problem am i solving and what kind of
layers will make sense at what
composition of those layers will make
sense so the next step is compiling the
model and and I've talked about this a
little bit before but we're really
what's happening here in Kerris is that
when we compile a model we're converting
the layers into a tensor flow graph and
we're then saying we have the layers
converted into a graph then we take the
lost function we add back to the graph
we take an optimizer add that to the
graph and then we say what metrics you
want to collect and we add that to the
graph so this is really just building
the graph that we're going to execute
the carest API has a whole bunch of loss
functions you can actually write your
own loss functions as you might expect
so different tasks require different
loss functions they have a bunch of
different optimizer some of which work
better for different types of data and
different tasks they have a bunch of
different metrics built-in metrics and
as you'd expect you can write your own
metrics that let you evaluate you know
the efficacy of your model as you're as
you're training it all of this that I
just talked about is articulated much
much better in the cares for our
cheat sheet you don't need again to get
this link down because I'll give you a
link to the slides this is also easy to
find on our tensorflow for our website
which I'll give you a link to as well
the cheat sheet is a great gives you a
great 10,000 foot view of everything
that I just talked about and the syntax
for it so what are some examples
actually using our to solve these
problems with the tools the Charis tools
that i just talked about we actually
have a gallery on the tensorflow for our
website and the gallery is a bunch of
in-depth blog posts that basically talk
about problems the motivation the data
set how we train the model what went
right what went wrong some intermediate
data visualizations for diagnostics of
the model speculation but how we can
improve it so they're really in-depth
blog posts about different application
areas all using the carrots for our
interface so I think once you get the
basics once you learn the basics this is
a great place to go next to kind of
learn about deeper application of
techniques the first thing I want to
talk about is actually I talked about
this idea of transfer learning where you
can actually train on a very small data
set and still get a really model that
performs really well this is an image
classification example that was trying
to predict whether an image is a dog or
a cat and was actually trained on only
2,000 images and the reason it could do
that it actually took a bunch of the of
the model that was used for that image
that data set has a lot of knowledge
about shapes and objects and things that
are related to dogs and cats it also
knows about you know other objects as
well vehicles and household appliances
and everything but we're able to build a
model on only 2000 input images using
this transfer learning technique and
this article kind of describes transfer
learning there's another article that
gives us sort of a primer in the
different ways you might do
timeseriesforecasting this is actually
whether time series data trying to
predict temperature and we talked about
using these recurrent layers I mentioned
stacking recurrent layers there's a
thing called bi-directional recurrent
layers that try to look at the data in
both forward and backward so there's a
good primer on some of the techniques
you would use in time series this is a
really interesting example of trying to
classify peptide
to figure out in cancer immunotherapy
when we introduce cells to treat cancer
how they're gonna bind to existing cells
so this is a it's a classification
problem looking at the peptide saying
how's the cell gonna bind and this
compares using a regular feed-forward
neural network against a random forest
and also tries to use a convolutional
model but the convolutional model ends
up not being better and so there's a
little discussion about to actually get
a bit get a better result what other
things can we try to get a better result
this is an example of trying to look at
a data set that has 300,000 credit-card
transactions
I think only 400 of which are fraudulent
so you know a typical logistic
regression might have trouble picking up
enough signal in the 400 fraudulent
transactions this is using a technique
called an auto encoder to try to try an
alternate way to try to figure out which
which transactions are fraudulent this
is a national natural language
processing example that tries to take
it's a data set of 400,000 pairs of
questions from Chora and tries to figure
out are they duplicates this also
demonstrating a shiny application as a
front-end to a Karass model which is
actually quite straightforward another
example of using a basic feed-forward
neural network to predict customer churn
and this demonstrates a couple other
interesting things it demonstrates using
a package called lime which we'll talk
about in a minute that while we can't
look at a deep learning model with
millions of parameters and say this is
how this phenomena works you can
actually take individual predictions and
you can figure out what features
contributed to that prediction so this
this is a dashboard that's actually also
built with shiny that says for this
customer what's their percent risk of
churn and then what attributes of that
customer actually contributed to that
prediction and then finally an example
from learning word embeddings which
talked about before we've got a database
of Amazon and food reviews and this is
an example of trying to learn a richer
vectorized representation of words than
just classifying the words which then
can be used later for parsing and
sentiment analysis of things like that I
want to address a little bit this issue
of explained ability because again these
models have really no explanatory power
when you look at all the coefficients
but there are ways to try to understand
how a prediction was made by a deep
learning model this is an example of a
model that's that's predicting what's in
the image and it's saying it's an
African elephant you can actually look
at the gradients of the intermediate
layers in the model and you can draw a
heat map out of that juxtapose that heat
map over the image you can say what
parts of that image actually contributed
to the to this prediction sort of
similar to what I talked about with lime
where you can say for an individual
prediction what features contributed to
it and when you're using these models to
do things like you know approved and I
credit or make a medical recommendation
it's really important even though the
model itself sits functioning as a black
box it's important to be able to
highlight well these are the reasons why
these are the things about the situation
that caused the model to go one way or
the other so kind of back to this deep
learning frontiers you know there are
many fields of inquiry I think where
people are going to use take a run
improving the state of the art using
deep learning most fields that we work
in now unless you're in computer vision
or maybe natural language processing
traditional statistical methods are
going to be cheaper they're gonna be
more accurate they're gonna be more more
reliable easier so yet there are these
frontiers and that's very that's very
compelling for a lot of people to say
well could we do better could we analyze
data that we're not currently able to
analyze so I think you can have a few
different approaches you can really take
a wait-and-see approach and say well
when might when I see that it's really
obvious in my field that people are
using deep learning a lot I'll use it
then you could you could follow research
and not just formal research but also
things people are lots of people are on
the internet experimenting and writing
blog posts about things could follow
that and kind of evaluate it and say do
I want to try that in my work or you can
even do your own research and try to say
I want to really get my head around all
this stuff works and I'm gonna be one of
the people who's trying to find that
frontier so there's a lot of different
approaches
I really want to highlight again that in
a lot of fields that the other than
these these kind of staples it's really
not there yet and and if you go looking
for these big wins it might be really
hard to find them I think what does it
look like if you are trying to approach
that frontier I think typically when
people succeed with building a deep
learning model they typically take it
can take a matter of weeks to actually
try all the different things the
different architectures the different
hyper parameters require to get the
model to work well I think when people
start using these tools they don't have
an intuition and then and then that
intuition is sort of developed over time
they tend to you need a lot of compute
power and you need tend to need tools
that help you manage experiments and get
the most out of the compute power that
you have so it's hard and in many ways
it may be the wisest thing maybe to wait
until you see people in your field
succeeding with it to try to get
involved in it but it's um
it's really it's really it's it's really
really interesting stuff to play with
and try out so I think a lot of people
are tempted and go and spend the time on
it and I think a lot of good things will
come out of it we've built a bunch of
supporting tools to help with this one
of the most important sets tools you
need to have especially if you're doing
convolutional networks or recurrent
neural networks is GPU they're really
these models convolutional and recurrent
models are really slow on CPUs so
there's a lot of different ways to use
GPUs if you have a current recent
high-end NVIDIA GPU on your local
workstation you can use that most people
many people vast majority people don't
there's other ways you can use GPUs in
the cloud in various ways that's
probably the easiest way or you can go
buy a buy a box and as a GPU that's
another way to go so the cloud is a
great is a great way to do this because
you could work locally on your laptop
and then when you need a lot of training
and compute power you can get it from
the cloud we've made we've done a couple
things to enable that we actually have a
an hour studio server with tensorflow
Amazon Marketplace image and it's not
it's it's
you know it's free and that you only pay
for the Amazon compute cost but this
actually has everything pre-installed
our studio tensorflow the Nvidia
libraries tiny verse got everything
pre-installed so this is a great way to
play around the GPU with very little
investment fixed cost investment there's
a package a cloud email package that
lets you do training on Google's cloud
ml using their GPUs and that's more like
a batch submission type service so the
so there's different ways to use dps in
our and our website covers that in
detail the intention for our website
covers that in detail we have a package
called TF runs I'm not going to actually
spend very much time on this but it's
used to manage training experiments so
just at the highest level you're gonna
run hundreds of training runs trying to
figure out what hyper parameters are the
best what model structure is the best so
instead of sourcing the R script that
runs the training you call this training
run function then we collect data on
every run we actually know all the
outputs of the run what the metrics of
the run were what the what the model was
what the source code was and so there's
a way of managing all your runs and you
can view reports on the runs you can
compare different runs you can establish
flags for runs and use that for doing
grid searches so the affronts package is
really good once you once you get past
the learning stage you're actually
trying to tune a model it's a really
good good way to go about doing that the
TF deploy package has tools for
deploying models again I said we don't
when we deploy a tensorflow model
there's no R or Python code it's just
C++ code so we have tools for working
with that again I'm not going to go into
that in a lot of detail but you the
process is you export your model and
then once you have an exported model you
can serve it with like a web server that
gives you a rest interface to it you can
serve it using an open source project
from Google called tensorflow serving
you can serve it with our studio konnekt
you can serve it with cloud ml so it's
sort of it this is sort of binary format
again sort of language runtime
independent that can be served in lots
and lots of different ways you can put
them inside a shiny application pretty
easily and one of the cool things is
that again this this idea
a model serialization that's not tied to
a language means that these models can
actually not just run on servers that
can run on embedded devices they can run
there's a Apple iOS as a thing called
core ml you can actually you can
actually feed Kerris models directly to
core ml so you you use R to train a
Karass model and then you deploy it on
an iPhone with no R on the iPhone
there's a library called Kara CAS that
lets you deploy these models into
JavaScript into the browser so there's
lots going on with taking these models
and making them deployable in lots of
places so that's that's really really
interesting to it so we'll try to build
tools that keep up with that and let you
do that all of that easily from within R
so biggest things I think to take away
think of tensorflow yes it's a deep
learning library but it's also this
numerical computing library that that's
hardware independent that's really fast
that we can do a lot of stuff within the
art community deep learnings done a lot
of great things with perception and I
think in some fields it's gonna make an
impact some some fields sooner some
fields later some fields not at all but
I think it's going to make an impact and
probably most importantly are now has
the best deep learning tools the Charis
and tensorflow out there we have a great
set of api's for them we have a bunch of
supporting tools so if you want to get
involved in this stuff and your use are
there's really wonderful support for
that now a lot of the stuff I talked
about tonight you can find at the
tensorflow for our website
easy-to-remember tensorflow to our
studio comm again i'm gonna give you a
link to these slides so you'll have that
link there so that's a good place to
start and the gallery I talked about and
documentation for all the packages is
all there this is important as Jared
said there's two books that I would
recommend reading if you're interested
in this and they're very very different
books the deep learning book on the
right is actually kind of the definitive
work in the field in terms of the
concepts and theory behind deep learning
the book has no code in it at all it's
all concepts and math the deep learning
with our book was actually written by
the creator of the Charis library
and I worked with him I didn't write my
name is on the cover by didn't write any
of the prose in the book I just adapted
he wrote the original book deep learning
with Python that was used with Karras
and I basically adapted it to the our
interface to Kharis so it's deep
learning with our this book is a really
good conceptual introduction to deep
learning it actually has no math all
code so it's all everything is done with
our code so one one has you know no math
all code the other has no code all math
depend on how you learn how you like to
approach problems you know read them in
whatever order you think is appropriate
but I think if you read these two books
you will know every just about
everything you need to know to get
started so thank you very much the
slides that I just went through are
available at the URL I have here I'll
keep the slide up and if you are
interested in this we have a blog censor
flow for our blog and that's where we
post announcements about packages and
other software releases but we also post
all those gallery entries the examples
those are also going on the blog too so
if you want to kind of stay up to date
and see what's happening and see what
kind of interesting examples the people
in the community are coming up with I
would urge you to visit and subscribe to
the blog so thank you very much
[Applause]
questions personal over here
thanks for an awesome
yeah
yeah the tensorflow uses CUDA and CUDA
DNN under the hood and typically what
you do is you run like nvidia diagnostic
tools to see like what your memory and
CPU utilization is so you know your and
you can't interact directly with CUDA
tensorflow is doing that but you can see
how the model is taking advantage or not
taking advantage of the GPUs and one of
the things that can happen is if you get
a model that's training really fast then
the bottleneck can actually become the
ingestion of the data and that's one of
the things that TF datasets package
addresses is to try to parallelize like
I'm reading and pre-processing the data
and I'm training at the same time so you
can have a model that's like only using
20% of the GPU because all the time is
spent in pre-processing that's not
getting data to the GPU fast ever yeah
yeah that's right yeah
yep
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so the our encoders like
learning an alternate representation of
the data and so I think the way that one
worked is that it took the non
fraudulent transactions and it learned
this other represented the auto encoded
them to another representation and then
it fed data through and it looked for
like prediction error and it said like
by hive dictionnaire on high prediction
error indicates it's probably not like
the things I auto encoded in the first
place and therefore is fraudulent yeah
yeah yes
yeah
yeah unfortunately I think there's a lot
of it is like witchcraft a lot of it is
really people just try stuff there isn't
Theory in fact what you I've heard talks
of people at Baidu saying the way we
train people is we just give them like
hundreds of examples and they just it's
like a cockpit simulation they just try
things so it's not I think in in a given
field
it might get narrower than that like in
computer vision it's like okay these
kind of layers with these kind of
parameters tend to work well but like
for something like this I don't think
there is a there's not a theory or
literature that says this is how this is
done there probably will be if there's
anything to find here there will be in a
few years but there isn't there isn't
right now yeah bleeding edge that's
right yeah
it's it should be this exact same
because it's it's really just using all
the same libraries yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah I think the key selling
point is that you like to use our for
doing data analysis you like the whole
our ecosystem you like working in our
studio you know that's really it's
because you prefer our and now you can
do all the same things in our that you
can do in Python I think if you already
prefer Python there's not a clear
motivation all right it's not because
it's really the same exact library just
with here's a here's a Python skin and
here's an our skin so
yes in fact yes do you already know the
answer to this coz yes so yes in fact if
you google has a thing called Auto ml
which literally it starts from no model
no model and it learns the whole model
the layers diagram prepares everything
and they actually have so they're doing
that I think they have a service called
Auto ml now that I think it does it for
computer vision but that is some
variation of that it's probably the
future that that I mean all the machine
learning engineers sitting and trying
grid searches of things and witchcraft
this and that that's probably not the
best way to approach this it's probably
some kind of combination of your
intuitions that you develop over time
and then machines looking and in the
space of models yeah yes so there's so
Karis has a thing called Karis
applications which are pre-trained
models so you'll see them it's called
Karis applications those are almost all
computer vision models and there's a
bunch of them those are the easiest to
use tensorflow has also I don't know if
it's called a model zoo but they have a
big collection of models those are
harder to use honestly from our than the
Charis models and and Karis has ported
most of the interesting models so yes
with Karis there's something similar I
don't know if it's comparable to the
depth or breadth of the model zoo that
cafe has but it's there
yep that's right that's right
yes it's a good question so you know
when you're writing a custom layer
you're basically so if you if you're
just composing layers really you just
have to train the model and see what
happens if you're writing a custom layer
or a custom lost function or custom
metric then you're basically writing
tensor the same sort of code that you
write in the lower level interface
you're basically doing the same thing
but inside a custom loss function or
metric or optimizer so those yes
the the debugging of those I think will
get better with there's a thing in
tensor flow coming called eager
evaluation which basically will the the
one of the problems of the graph is that
it's all deferred so you in are
nothing's to ferb and you add a you know
you a matrix multiplication it happens
you see the result there's a thing
coming intensive look on eager
evaluation will give you the same
semantics so then when you're building a
custom Kerris layer or loss function
you'll just be able to call it like a
function and test it and see what it
does
so I'd say when you're building the
custom things it's very similar to that
to that lower level interface
yeah so the efficiently I'll tell you
the way you you basically can build I
didn't show this but in carrots they
have this concept of a multi input model
so you can have a model that actually
takes in some vector data some image
data some sequence data and so you you
again it's I showed you the sequential
model which is just like a stack of
layers and that's most common but you
can build a graph of any level of
complexity so you typically will have
multiple inputs and then you'll they'll
get down to a certain point and then
you'll concatenate them in some way and
you'll maybe weight the concatenation of
them and Samba built-in yeah so like
you'll get all the data then you'll
flatten them and concatenate them
together so yeah that's how you do that
yes yeah yeah well it's one model that
has multiple inputs so I showed you
feeding input data like here's the X
data you could pass a list of dates so
you can have a model that has three
heads right it's got this takes an image
this takes some vector data and this
takes like a sequence of text and then
they all you feed them in in a list and
then they all at some point you actually
have multi outputs as well so you can
have multi inputs and multi outputs so
let's say you have a single output at
some point those lay their inputs are
gonna get concatenated together somehow
you're gonna wait them or you're gonna
do something that says okay I've got
these different factors they they what
happens is the standard I see typically
like the standardize them you might just
flatten them so you've got a tensor it's
2d or 3d you just flatten it out in a
bunch of numbers and then concatenate
them together it's like a big soup of
numbers and then you and then you feed
it through the dense layers after that
so you're not it you're it's not like
you're writing a program you're saying
I'm very explicitly like I'm gonna
normalize them and put them together
you're just gonna like slam them
together and put some weights on them
and then let the network see if that
lets the network build good predictions
can't can't can't hear you yeah yeah
in computer vision you're talking about
computer vision I think people are using
these kind of models I don't want to say
exclusively but this is like really the
predominant way people build computer
vision systems now it wasn't five years
ago
but that's not necessarily the case in
like natural language processing and
natural language processing it's so
mostly traditional things and the people
are experimenting with it with this
yeah
I don't think somewhat I can see and
people are trying really hard
I think the deep-learning performs
really well with like really really
messy day that data that's hard to
encode it's hard to feature engineer has
a lot of noise in it you know that's the
kind of data that it does well on but if
the data is like vector data that's like
well structured and understood it's
almost impossible to be you know the
tools that we already have and then D
blaring doesn't really add much in those
cases
yeah
oh you mean oh that yeah people play
with that that validation split
depending on the type of data that
they're you know that varies depending
on what the type of model you're
building like how much data you need to
hold out I don't know I'm not sure I
don't know
[Applause]